big story is the complete closure of a
very busy Northeast intersection by a
multiple car crash upwards of five or
six cars involved we know of at least
two injuries but that's all we know so
far Lam and Bonanza shot down in all
four directions thank you to viewer
Jacqueline Tompkins for sending in this
horrific video debris all over the place
car pieces Parts here and there uh one
car may be up on the roof uh turned over
here's what it looks like from the
Regional Transportation Commission
camera an even better view from our very
own photographer Stacy on the scene
multiple cars and all kinds of debris on
the road so back to the traffic camera
we go for how are you going to get
around this again Bonanza lamb closed
for East-West travel with Bonanza shut
down pretty easy to go up north to
Washington or down south to Stuart with
lamb North and South closed pretty easy
to head over to Nellis as an alternative
to the east or perhaps Pecos over to the
West rest of the freeway system really
good shape right now John